démarrer justement avec vos bonnes
résolutions pour cette année 2023 je
vais vous montrer dans l'écran derrière
moi les résolutions que nous avons
toutes données tous donnés dans la
semaine et vous allez devoir savoir à
qui elles appartiennent ces résolutions
on commence tout de suite avec tiens
utilisez enfin mon abonnement à la salle
de sport enfin c'est toi Michel c'est
toi c'est toi c'est toi non j'ai pas
d'abonnement
j'ai une salle de sport je vais pas les
citer les cercles de je sais pas quoi ou
les carrés de la Ford ils sont en bas de
chez moi ça fait deux ans et demi tous
les mois mais 39 balles ou je sais pas
quoi je n'y ai jamais mis les pieds donc
voilà c'est ma bonne résolution et je
pense que ça me fait du bien
participer à un télé-crochet qu'est-ce
qui a pu dire ça
[Applaudissements]
je trouverai un moyen de participer en
télécroché que ce soit Nouvelle Star la
France incroyable en Star Academy
n'importe quoi
fais-nous 10 secondes une chanson vas-y
il a quand même jukebox 10 secondes
vas-y acapella
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour apprendre et fonctionner
des stars de la chanson les plus connues
du monde la même passe dans les 200
premières il y a même pas ces millions
que je crois Françoise
seul du classement elle est chargée
absolument
du jury
arrêter d'envoyer
alors c'est qui c'est qui
une toute petite question mon Benoit
quand tu fais un nude comme tu dis ouais
il se passe quoi concrètement ça tu
choisis la partie de ton corps tu fais
une lumière tu fais quoi non alors c'est
vrai j'ai cette fâcheuse habitude
alors vas-y alors j'ai ce gros problème
c'est que sur Instagram quand je
commence à chiner un peu j'ai des
bailles avec des mecs qui me plaisent
des bagues les plus vieux des bail c'est
des histoires des histoires et tout et
ben j'ai cette fâcheuse habitude tout de
suite dans le jour où le lendemain
d'envoyer un peu les parties et tout
mais j'adore je pense que c'est
générationnel par exemple c'est pas ta
générationnel
ah on peut avoir des noms
[Musique]
quel est le nude le plus rapide que tu
as envoyé après un premier contact avec
quelqu'un au bout de combien de temps je
dirais au bout de 20 minutes
est-ce que j'ai peur c'est qu'un jour
les photos sortent parce que oui
c'est pas grave mais pourquoi tu
continues à faire bah je sais pas c'est
obsession
pourquoi tu veux arrêter absolument
[Applaudissements]
je vous rappelle si vous êtes chez vous
entre dessus c'est de conversation
extrêmement intéressantes sur les photos
de la pub de Benoît et bien que je
présente cette émission pendant encore 5
10 minutes car Matthieu Delormeau qui
n'envoie jamais de New de lui
arrive dans quelques secondes mais
pardonnez-moi mais ça c'est une vieille
réflexion c'est pas lui que je l'envoie
mais tout le monde les voit donc ton
père aussi mais non je les envoie en
privé
on passe à la résolution suivante rester
célibataire
qui est déjà célibataire Jean-Michel
Natacha c'est Natacha oui mais c'est pas
un choix vas-y c'est toi c'est pas toi
c'est pas moi
mais oui
pourquoi tu en as marre des mecs j'ai
décidé d'un certain assétisme voilà
émotionnel
la mienne c'est d'arriver à l'heure
[Applaudissements]
non mais non
on a rien fait très intime les
résolutions
où j'étais l'interview Royal tu sais où
j'étais non hier j'étais en Angleterre
explique-leur on en a parlé on en a
parlée
je suis parti pour rencontrer Charles je
sais Benoît
je suis parti pour rencontrer Charles
III
j'ai vu la grille du Buckingham
non j'ai vu plein de gens mais lui n'a
pas voulu alors regarde on en est la
quatrième résolution oui donc la mienne
c'est me faire baiser
avec Sophie
j'avais entendu une très bonne vanne
devenant mais c'est pas par choix pour
Natacha et en général
les gens qui sont célibataires YouTube
mets-toi en couple bah mon nom
ça va mon grand tu es gentil
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
en mesure anticoïde vous les avez
vous avez toutes faites ouais on a on
est à changer mais célibataire Sophie je
croyais qu'il était en couple changer
la personne
célibataire fait partie de ces gens et
j'avais un petit peu ce pardon et Sophie
mental mais tout le monde s'en [ __ ]
t'inquiète pas une voyante va arriver
j'ai lu ta fiche ton année va être
catastrophique
non mais je vais être catastrophique
dans une petite piscine
j'aurais fait pas le sommaire
exceptionnel mais tu aurais dû arriver
un petit peu plus tard c'est pas faux ça
ouais c'est pas faux
résolutions non toi le petit problème
que tu as ma chérie c'est qu'en fait tu
tu es en couple mais avec en fait en
fait c'est qu'il y a 16 personnes en
France qui pensent que tu es en couple
avec elle j'ai déjà eu ça moi aussi
quand tu es gentil à table tu dis bah
écoute on se met en couple tu dis oui
puis oui puis tu sais pas dire non puis
il y a un moment
pas du tout vous pensez qu'en fait les
gens pensent que je suis en couple avec
plein de personnes différentes pas du
tout non non ça fait 4 ans que je suis
avec la même personne
de rentrer dans une espèce de ce qu'on
appelle une autarcie émotionnelle vous
voyez c'est se connaître un peu mieux
soi-même pour voir éventuellement tu
l'as déjà dit à ton mec que tu allais
faire de l'autarcie émotionnel
en fait tu le dis quoi
ça s'appelle la dépression
si ça te dirait qu'on fasse l'amour on
l'appelle 3 semaines série ce soir c'est
retard si émotionnel avant il y avait
mal de tête chez les filles les choses
et les choses
évolue alors il y a qui on avait pas
fait le reste je crois je crois que la
plus drôle ça a été ça a été gentil
on y va on continue celle-là elle a
changé de cheveux c'est qui
alors ma banane
[Applaudissements]
depuis qu'on a démarré l'émission
un jour avec Jean-Michel qui lui a fait
des petits rage tout ça et voilà
il a fini
il m'a expliqué un peu le concept etc
j'ai trouvé ça rigolo et je me suis dit
pourquoi pas un jeu c'est quoi ce sac
mais qu'est-ce que ça peut te [ __ ]
c'est un buzz en ville tout à l'heure je
reparle en Angleterre tu vois donc voilà
je me suis dit pourquoi pas surprendre
le public cette année avec un jour mais
non une nouvelle chevelure
j'en ai pas mal j'en ai mais là pas là
j'en ai j'en ai marre
attendez parce que le sujet me passionne
mais juste avant parce que les gens se
disent on va faire une émission
résolution je vous dis quand même déjà
une excellente année pardon parce que on
arrive comme ça
le meilleur vraiment pour vous la santé
surtout l'amour le reste
[Musique]
le gars c'était mon idole physiquement
le métier qui devait il était beau il
avait tout il a monté une start-up qui
pèse des millions le gars complètement
réussi des millions ou des millions
c'est un regard du cul donc j'avais dit
la vitesse
alors j'ai cru tu verras parce qu'un
jour il est venu avec un petit chien
dans mon bureau comme ça qui te nage et
dit ça y est pour moi
et en fait pas du tout non non
complètement hétéro les petits chiens
alors en revanche on sweat vous vous
souvenez de leur petite bon oui la Star
Ac et c'est une fille qui est formidable
qui avait marqué la Star Ac marqué aussi
parce que c'est la première fille comme
ça son âge qui avait fait un coming out
dans une émission qui faisait 10
millions de téléspectateurs ensuite elle
est partie vivre à l'étranger ensuite
elle s'est elle a totalement changé de
vie je veux pas vous dire ce qu'elle
fait maintenant mais elle est très
heureuse et je lui ai passé un petit
coup de fil je lui est-ce que tu peux
venir à la Montpellier elle dit ça me
fait plaisir de nouveau excuse-moi
question tu dis elle a fait un coming
out à l'époque et étudier elle est
mariée
[Musique]
et on est en 2023 elle vient de parler
[Applaudissements]
il y a des gens il
y a des gens qui sont devenus héros on a
Jean-Pierre Bellemare en plateau il
n'est pas il est pas au courant des
sauts
il y aura les IP il y a les potins on
parle du biopic sur Brigitte Bardot qui
fait un scandale à l'incroyable on a des
scoops on a un énorme scoop sur Fauve
Hautot on a bossé hein tu as la voix
j'ai tout donné en fait j'étais dans la
grille du Buckingham
je te l'ai dit hier
personne m'a ouvert il fait un froid
là-bas allez on continue vous pouvez me
remettre les petits parce que c'était
très drôle idée de Déborah très drôle
réapprendre à faire l'amour ah
c'est toi Jean-Michel tu plaisantes
arrive
jamais cette phrase le jeune court vite
le vieux connait le chemin
très bonne donc Isabelle et moi on
s’essouffle un peu on tachycard mais du
coup on sait quoi faire et voilà vous
vous énervez là les petits jeunes
[Applaudissements]
c'est d'abord c'est moi
désolé
apprendre tu fermes les yeux
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
bien sûr mais
c'est pas mon téléphone parce que je
voulais l'appeler Faustine Bollaert pour
les plateaux de l'après-midi tu
donnerais parler salut aurait fait
tellement plaisir sinon en revanche il y
a un très bon professeur autour de cette
table
il est amoureux laisse-le tranquille
j'ai vu jouer Nadal
Jean-Michel
en boîte de nuit vous aviez la même
chambre et c'était quoi le délire bah
non mais j'attendais dehors
mais si tu veux si tu veux j'étais comme
un enfant qui est à Roland-Garros qui
peut pas se payer les billets mais quand
on est oh oh
je sais tes matchs et match
apprendre à faire de l'humour c'est
alors lever un peu le pied sur le boulot
ça ça peut être noir c'est Jean-Mi c'est
Jean-Michel alors c'est très ironique
parce que qui a écrit un bouquin ici
elle est excellent d'ailleurs ah non je
pense que c'est Jean-Mi moi c'est
Jean-Michel
ah merci mon cœur
[Applaudissements]
mangera à chaque fois on mangera un
fruit
et en commandant comme en 2023 je vais
vous dire moi je me suis fait une to do
listes de choses à faire et j'ai des
choses à corriger et des choses voilà
très peu Mathieu merci et dans les
choses que je vais pas corriger parce
que finalement ce que tu es embrasses le
c'est toi Shakespeare et bien finalement
j'ai décidé que j'allais être moi-même
et moi-même et ben c'est que je vais
manger les bananes j'ai toujours été un
petit peu capricieux alors voilà alors
la prochaine pause je veux une mangue
qui vient directement des Antilles
et si tu ne la trouve pas tu seras
licencié
et la suivante en train de papaye
la suivante
[Rires]
tique de la chirurgie esthétique je me
dis que il y a des manuels qui te
prennent comment triturer la peau pour
qu'elle soit pour réveiller les muscles
de la peau
mais vous savez on va commencer
l'émission mais cette j'ai passé des
vacances
on peut à Paris un peu moyenne et là
j'ai regardé beaucoup de conférences tu
sais il y a beaucoup de conférences qui
sont alors moi je la regarde aux États
au Canada parce que c'est en français
alors ils adorent ça aux États-Unis
comment les mieux comment
comment gagner de l'argent et j'en ai
regardé notamment sur les résolutions et
il y a un professeur qui a dit donc je
vous le dis chez vous vous faites une
liste de 10 choses qui sont importantes
pour vous sur les 10 il y en a une qui
va vous sauter aux yeux et c'est ce
qu'on appelle un bloqueur c'est quelque
chose qui fait que ça vous empêche dans
votre vie d'avancer celle qui vous saute
aux yeux celle-là vaut la prenait de la
liste et cette chose là vous mettez 10
manières de l'atteindre mais facilement
et on vous disant que l'échec est
possible et 10 façons de l'atteindre moi
par mois et vous verrez que vous
enlèverez ce qu'on appelle un bloqueur
dans une vie et si vous dans un métier
dans une vie amoureuse et tout vous
allez passer un ça merci merci
c'est vrai mais c'est mon prochain
métier je serai conférencier